Good morning. Welcome to Trinity Fellowship. Thank you, Brandon, for opening us and James and
Dan and Mary. Thank you all for leading us in worship this morning. Let's first, let's
give you a second to turn to Psalm 10. Now, read it for us. It's also, it's in the worship guide
on, I think, page three. So, I think that... Why, oh Lord, do you stand far away? Why do you
hide yourself in times of trouble? In arrogance, the wicked hotly pursue the poor. Let them be caught
in the schemes they have devised for the wicked boast of the desires of his soul.
The one greedy for gain curses and renounces the Lord. In the pride of his face, the wicked
does not seek him. All his thoughts are there is no God. His ways prosper at all times.
Your judgments are on high out of his sight. As for all his foes, he puffs at them. He says in his
heart, I shall not be moved. Throughout all generations, I shall not meet adversity.
His mouth is filled with cursing and deceit and oppression. Under his tongue are mischief and
iniquity. He sits in ambush in the villages and hiding places he murders the innocent.
His eyes stealthily watch for the helpless. He lurks in ambush like a lion in the thicket.
He lurks that he may seize the poor. He seizes the poor when he draws him into his net.
The helpless are crushed. He sink down and fall by his might. He says in his heart,
God has forgotten. He has hidden his face. He will never see it.
Arise, O Lord. O God, lift up your hand. Forget not the afflicted. Why does the wicked renounce
God and say in his heart, You will not call to account, but You do see. For You note mischief
and vexation that You may take it into Your hands. To You, the helpless commits himself.
You have been the helper of the fatherless. Break the arm of the wicked and evildoer.
Call his wickedness to account till You find none. The Lord is king forever and ever.
The nations perish from his land. O Lord, You hear the desire of the afflicted.
You will strengthen their heart. You will incline your ear to do justice to the fatherless and
to the oppressed, so that man who is of the earth may strike terror no more.
Let us pray. Father, we come to You today ready to hear Your Word, ready to walk as Your Word would
tell us. Lord, help us when we come in times of trouble to come to You, to pray to You.
Lord, guide us today. Help our ears to hear what You would have us to hear.
And this we pray. Amen.
Lord, why do You stand far away? Why do You hide in times of trouble?
Do these questions leave you a bit uneasy? Maybe asking, is the Bible accusing God of being far
away? Is the Bible saying that God is hiding Himself from our troubles? These are shocking
questions and they shape how we approach the Psalm. These questions make us ask about,
what about this world would make someone say that God is distant?
And should we talk to God like this? And what is even true about God?
First, some context may help us. Psalm 10 continues the lament from Psalm 9,
as we have often discussed, the Psalms are prayer songs, songs that provide a window into
emotion and beauty and the truth that words on their own would struggle to accomplish.
At the center of our Bibles, there's songs that express the granders of life, like we saw in
Psalm 8. But also the dark and the difficult times, like Psalm 9 and Psalm 10, our Bibles are
beautifully complex. They neither gloss over the difficult times, nor do they leave us out of
the awe and the amazement of what God has done in this world. So to come to this Psalm, let's
first just look at the wicked one. The wicked one embodies what we could call the biblical bad guys.
He rages like Cain and he boasts like Pharaoh. He's self-centered like Saul and he's greedy like
King Ahab. You see, verses 2 through 11 kind of show us this world that is inhabited by
unjustice, injustice and unfair afflictions. So who is this wicked one? Wickedness, when used here
in Psalm 9, is describing the relationship between the wicked one and God. See, the wicked one,
he ignores God's reign. He scoffs at God. Instead of making God ruler, he becomes his own ruler.
He's the source of his own right and wrong. He defines his own moral compass. He goes in his own
direction. You could call this a practical atheist, though he may not be making a mental decision or
a thoughtful decision on whether or not God is real. He lives as though God doesn't.
In fact, he chooses to take an act based on his own desires. See, verse 3, it says,
for the wicked boasts of the desires of his soul.
In his heart, he despises God and desires to fill himself with his own desires, his own sinful
pleasures. We call this pride. I like the way Eugene Peterson puts verse 4. He says,
the words of the wicked are, catch us if you can. God is dead. Or in verse 6, he says,
we can't go wrong. This is our lucky year. It's hubris. It's saying that nothing can come against me.
I'm strong enough. I'll make it through on my own. He doesn't acknowledge the goodness that
God brings to him. And he decides that everything's in his own power. It's in his own grasp. He can
grab it. But this comes at a cost. If you notice, the enemy or the wicked one, his pride, has to feed
on something, feeds on the needy. While pride builds a palace, the afflicted are burying its burden.
And if you notice, the strategy works. It says, his way is prosper. When we experience an all-to-and-
troubling world, we can turn our eyes to God who sees us and lift our voice to a God who hears us.
We can lean on a God who is faithful to bring about justice.
We may look into the world and notice that this is real. We often run into times where
people have belittled someone in order to make themselves better. We may not have to go too far.
We can think of wars in recent history or current. We can think about maybe our workplaces where
we consider lying about someone in order to grow and go up the chain. But this isn't the point to
remember that inward corruption doesn't stay inward. It moves out. We look in verse seven for a second.
His mouth is filled with cursing and deceit and oppression. His inward way he is inwardly moves
out and it attacks with words. Verse eight talks about how he's stalking and ready to attack.
In verse 10 he crushes. It's what oppression, the crushing, the pressing down.
Verse nine, he seizes the poor.
For his ways to prosper he needed to seize and crush the innocent.
So we should stay on guard. The world and its enemies are seeking to trap us by providing lures that
feed our egos. How can we be on guard against pride? If we notice it's easy to call out someone
who's prideful or does things but sometimes it's harder to look inward and find that in ourselves.
So how can we, one way we can give, if we noticed that throughout the Bible and in the Psalm it's
God who gives to the fatherless and to the poor, we too we can give and by giving we take something
out of ourselves and give it to someone else. We can give credit to God for the one who gives
all good things. We can give aid to one another when we see people in need we can help.
We can help others instead of ourselves.
We can act like God caring for the needy.
It's in the midst of the pain of the world that evil in the world offers us a scheme,
something to pull us in. It lures us. It offers us solutions to a long day and maybe sex or
in money or in power. It finds that maybe a long day looks out of worldly comfort or a deep
insecurity grasped onto a false power. When the world that we live in troubles us it often pushes us
to find a worldly solution. In a troubled world, the world we live in, the world offers us troubled
answers. This is the troubled world we live in, a world where troubled people make trouble.
I think Psalm 10 is just being honest about the world. The practical atheism of the wicked
shows that he has no desire to turn toward God and a godless world does not give us any reason
to care for one another. A godless world doesn't see the humanity of an orphan, doesn't give us
or show the beauty of a human being, the beauty of a needy.
We should remember that they too were people made by God, made to be in relationship with him and
made to be ruled by him not by us. Now while Psalm 10 turns the wicked into a person, it
personifies wickedness. We may experience wickedness not in a person but in tragedies.
Our minds can go to the summer camp in Texas where a flood ripped through the summer camp
or last week an 18-year-old was shot in Birmingham in a different way. We often throw the
divorce statistic around like it's just numbers. Instead we can look and see a family torn apart.
The world we live in sometimes can leave us hopeless. I think a world that's hopeless would
cause someone to cry out, where are you God? God are you avoiding us?
So what do we do? What do we do when we're in a world that is troubled?
Where should we turn in times of trouble? Should I accuse God of being far away or
should I ask for God to break the arm of the wicked? Well the thing is that the world we
live in should cause us to despair and be angry. It's not as good as we think it is.
The other day I was scrolling through and I saw a video of a lady on a plane. She was
attacking another lady with verbal insults and then like pulling on her hair. Something inside
of me boiled. There was something unsettling about that picture of somebody attacking and
demeaning and belittling another human. That type of pain was not meant for
the world we live in. Earlier in the year we studied the book of Ephesians and Paul instructs
us in the book of Ephesians to be angry but do not sin. I think Brandon put this well. He said
there is such a thing as righteous indignation. Christians should not be indifferent to the
injustice we see in the world. It's that same verse that Paul tells us that are angry
can give a foothold to the devil for our enemy. We should remember that our human anger
is limited because of our lack of self control. When we see injustice or evil played out in the world,
we can quickly respond in a way that's just as sinful as what's being committed. We can quickly
just latch on and attack as well. So we should be careful. Last week we learned that God is
the righteous judge. So what can we do? We can bring our anger to God because he's the only
one who can deal perfectly with injustice. He's the only perfect one and he alone can set
right what is unjust. What about our sadness? A world that oppresses or pushes us down may
lead us to despair. A dark world may cloud over the sky where we can't see into the heavens but
we just look around on the earth to find another solution, an earthly solution. I like to camp
and hike and I think some of us men as we've hiked before, we can imagine how beautiful it is to go and
to spend time in God's creation and in nature. It's beautiful. We can genuinely find joy in
walking up to a mountain lake and enjoying that beautiful time.
But I think we could all admit that when we get back, our legs might get a little sore or
we come back to Monday morning and we're back in the same routine that we've been in.
In short, worldly solutions often just leave us either wanting more or hurting us in return.
Perhaps we want to seek out whether it's therapeutic medicine or whether it's
sinful vices that we may seek out to deal with the despair that's inside of us.
We should know their limits that they can't be the end if my goal in life is to be in the
woods on a Saturday. I'm going to be disappointed when Monday comes around.
So where should we go? Well, let's look at verse 12. Our psalmist, he says, arise, oh Lord,
oh God, lift up your hand. We can truly say, oh why God is this world bad? Why do you stand far away?
We don't leave it there. Where do we go? We go to him and we say, God, come.
We can go to the Lord. We can pray to him and call out words like the words of this psalm.
Our imperfect pleas are heard by a perfect God.
When Jesus taught us to pray, he said, thy kingdom come, thy will be done on earth as it is in heaven.
These are the words asking God to come and to heal a broken land.
And as we read earlier, we can approach God with confidence because of what he has done faithfully.
And when our prayers come into the courts of God, we will not find a judge who is hidden or is
lazy or corrupt. No, we'll find an attentive God. This is my final point. We look in verse 12.
It says, arise, oh Lord, oh God, lift up your hand. So it moves from describing the wicked one now to
moving to God and what God can do. David, like the people of God, calls upon the Lord to remember
his people. God does see the wicked and the evil in this world. Verse 14 says, but you do see.
There's the turn. You do see.
We also know that God is our source of strength. God strengthens his people in weakness.
You look at verse 17. It says, you hear the desire of the afflicted and you will strengthen their
heart. Take, for instance, Paul. Paul was often beaten and stoned almost to the point of death.
And yet what happens? He keeps going and he, he pleads to God to take away his thorn in the flesh.
But here's what, here's what he learns. He says, for the sake of, for the sake of Christ, then I am
content with weakness, insults, hardship, persecution and calamities. For when I am weak, then I
am strong. You see, our weakness is the opportunity for God's strength.
I recently got to hear from a, he's a, he's a president of a seminary in Ukraine. He came to
visit and he said, his name is Ivan Rusyn and he talked about how before the war in Ukraine,
the evangelicals couldn't get chaplaincies. They struggled to have counselors and chaplains to go
out. But because of the war, the ability was opened up. I think you can see how, in spite of
disaster, in spite of terrible injustice, there is, there's an answer from God. Here's what he
said though. He said, as a pastor, it's a unique moment. We cannot just help people to overcome
their traumas. We can demonstrate the beauty of the gospel to them. Our weakness is the very
opportunity for God to show his power, his grace, his good news is enough. It's sufficient for us.
So in verse 18, we can see that there's coming a day where God will and does do justice to the oppressed,
that the man who is of the earth will strike terror no more. There will be a day when the orphan in
the house will be vindicated. We have learned that our God is focused on us. He's attentive.
So when our enemies' eyes stealthily watch, we know that God does see. Even takes notes.
Our God keeps his eyes on the enemy and has his pen ready to write. And when the enemy lies in
ambush to seize the poor, our God takes injustice into his hands. The good news is that our
God is not unaware of the bystander. He doesn't just stand on the side.
Some time teaches us that he hears our cry and that he will incline his ear.
He will not let evil rule on the earth forever. In fact, he come down to get a closer look
in a human body. He experienced that injustice for himself. In Jesus' final week, he looked out
over the city of Jerusalem and he cried. Instead of hearing prayers and worship in the temple,
he heard bartering. Instead of self-sacrificial teachers, he saw teachers imposing
on their followers burdens. In short, they had neglected justice and mercy and faithfulness.
But Jesus himself was rejected by that same world. The same world that we experienced, he experienced.
So I want to read a poem for you that I recently saw. And I want to give the warning that it's a
little blunt and it starts off a little tough. But I think as we have examined the world that we
live in, we'll see that the world can be a little tough. It's called Sparrows by a man named Bryce
Taylor. Let me get a drink. It says, there was a girl in my high school always smiling.
And the other day in a bathtub, she shot herself. Her mother was downstairs with her two little kids
whose universe will begin with that bang. Somehow there's still air in the lungs of earth
to blow through the reeds and random sparrows still are flying. The sacred, the scarred,
eternal intellect threading the spider that threads its orb web to catch, immobilize,
and guzzle the juices. Yesterday, black vultures in my neighborhood quarreled over rubbery pink
remains of a squirrel run over on a street where kids play. Manichaeans were onto something separating
a good god from all of this. But you're so stubborn. You insist on hanging dead in the web
and being there in the tub. Not pulling the trigger maybe, but kissing the wrinkled finger
as it pulled.
Jesus didn't find it enough just to stand on the side. He decided to come and experience this world
himself. He was sped on and he was beaten and he was put on a cross and he experienced death.
Philosopher Theologian named James K. Smith, he put it this way, what is offered is not an
answer to evil as if it were merely a problem or a question. Instead, what is offered is the
vision of a gracious action of God who takes on evil. Our God doesn't just say to the question
why are you far away, he doesn't just give an answer. He comes and he takes on that evil.
He does something with it. He bears it and he vanquishes it.
We look to the vision of John when he sees a new creation. What does he see? He sees
a world where God's people dwell with him. He sees a world where tears are wiped away.
We can know that in the midst of injustice when God seems far away,
we can know he remains on the throne and he will bring about justice.
We experience an all too real and troubling world but we're not alone. We can turn our eyes
to the God who sees us. We can lift our voice to the God who hears us and we can lean on the God
who is faithful to bring about injustice. Let us pray. Father, we give you thanks
for all that you have done for us. We thank you for your kindness, for your grace.
We thank you for bearing the burden of our world.
God, we desire to come to you. Then our darkness, we see a light. We see you shining.
Lord, help us to walk in the lamp of your word. Help us to walk according to that guide.
Lord, help us to care for the lowly. Lord, help us to listen to your word. We pray in Jesus' name. Amen.